welcome back to pftpm we have been doing
this
every tuesday all season long and it
really is amazing we are already looking
at
week number 14. back in the old days
when shireen and i discovered the nfl
that was it week 14 it was done season
was over show isn't over though stick
with us even though the pft pm graphic
is up i assume that
the show continues here we are we're
back but sheree remember those days when
it was just 14 weeks and that was it we
went straight to the playoffs and there
was no wild card
round there were divisional round and
conference championship and they usually
played the super bowl not
very long after the first of the year
but we still have three more weeks of
the regular season and before we get to
week 15
we have to hand out the week 15 or week
14 excuse me awards mds joins us now
let's do it like we always do offensive
defensive rookie
and coach of the week mds you're up
first with the offensive player of the
week
well i'm going with lamar jackson who
just had such an outstanding
game on monday night he had a double
triple my favorite stat
more than 100 yards both rushing and
passing
he had that great moment when he went
straight from the locker room
to the field and threw a touchdown pass
and he looked more like the mvp
we saw last year than he had looked for
most of this year
when he has struggled that time this
year's ravens team has not been as good
as last year's ravens team
lamar jackson and others included but i
still think they're gonna go to the
playoffs and i think they're gonna be a
tough team to beat
if lamar jackson plays like he did last
night
completely agree with you mds he was
excellent second hundred yard rushing
game of the season
i went with travis kelsey i just felt
like it was time we gave
travis kelsey some love we haven't given
him award this year and he leads the nfl
in receiving yards and we know a tight
end has never done that he's got a
chance actually to break a
uh several tight end awards uh records
including yards and catches and
and everything else is going to take
quite a bit to do it the rest of the
season but on a day that patrick mahomes
didn't have his best day with three
interceptions
i thought travis kelsey had his best day
eight catches 136 yards
and a touchdown the last two two weeks
he's caught exactly 136 yards so you
might roll the dice and bet for three
weeks in a row 136 yards
but five of the last six weeks he's over
100 yards and really playing at a high
level i think on the all-pro team
he's a lock for tight end for that team
he's played terrific this season and
played terrific on sunday
and he's got hall of fame credentials
the way he's played the last several
years it helps to have patrick holmes
but this is what we see
in every generation there's a dominant
team in what happens
a bunch of those guys end up in the hall
of fame after they get their
statistics their awards and ultimately
their super bowl rings and they very
well may be getting a second one this
year
kelsey could be the first tight end in
league history to lead the league in
receiving yards that was an idea that
mds planted last week we looked it up we
confirmed it and indeed
he's on track to do it and uh maybe he
ultimately will my
player of the week is a guy who has a
chance
and the only guy who would have the
chance to pull this off is
derek henry over the final three weeks
if he has three derek henry games
we could see him go from 1532
to 21.05 and wouldn't that be something
he needs 191 yards
in each of the last three games on
average to get to 2105. and 191
sounds incredibly unrealistic
and improbable for anyone but derek
henry we consider the teams they're
playing
he has the chance to do it and he's
going to be aware of it and the titans
need him
the only question is will they curtail
his workload in anticipation
of the post season or just let him
go for it and i would try to find a way
to keep him fresh and keep him
safe and and be relatively careful but
you know when he busts through the line
and runs for 60 yards it's not like he's
going to go down halfway through so
if he can play like he's been playing he
has a chance to do it for now he's my
offensive player of the week
and i hope i hope especially because
he's plus 10 000
from an odds making perspective to win
the league mvp award i hope he doesn't i
hope there's someone out that's put 100
bucks
on derrick henry to win the mvp because
that would be the ultimate disruption of
this patrick mahomes aaron rodgers
presumption of the league mvp award all
right defensive player of the week mds
who do you have
well i have a guy who some people talked
about as a long shot
mvp candidate when he first arrived in
chicago
and made such a huge impact and i'm
talking about khalil mack
and you know this year in chicago
there's been some talk that he's not
playing at that level
maybe it's because he's been on the
injury report a lot maybe
uh he's not as good when he's not in vic
fangio's defense
as he was in his first year with the
bears but he had a great game on sunday
he did a little bit of everything
he had a sack he had a safety and a
force fumble he had a fumble recovery
he deflected a pass uh he had a tackle
for loss
he just was doing it all and he was that
kind of player that the bears
really need him to be if they can
justify what they gave up to get him
and how much they're paying him they
need him to play at that level
if he has a future in chicago and if
chicago is going to
turn things around that's the khalil mac
that they need to see
and i thought he turned in one of his
very best
games as a bear in that big win over the
texans
he sure did mds and i took the easy way
out i
picked hassan reddick of course with the
five sacks and the three force fumbles
he had seven
pressures on 22 pass rushing attempts so
just an outstanding game from reddick
and it was probably the best pass
rushing game that we've seen since
adrian claiborne had those
six sacks against the cowboys in 2017
and
chaz green that's probably the last that
that we've seen of him
uh in a backup role i know he's kind of
getting maybe some starts elsewhere but
he's
not played very well since then and and
i think that probably ruined chaz green
but seven is a record derek thomas he
didn't quite get there but it was an
outstanding performance by hassan
reddick on sunday
and redick didn't just abuse one guy he
had three different people he beat to
get to five he didn't even know he had
five until the end of the game
he never had more than two in any
football game at any level of his entire
football career for me it's it's easy
it's aaron donald just it's aaron donald
every week they
they need to name the defensive player
of the week award after
aaron donald he had a second half he has
the lead with 12 and a half this year
and the quote from sean mcvay and i
think mdsu wrote the story about it that
on the pick six
that the rams had it was aaron donald
out in front
leading the way to block for the
touchdown so he can do it all
he is incredible he should be without
question the defensive player of the
year
in 2020 and he could be the defensive
player of the week each and every week
and one of the reasons why the rams are
nine and four and still have a chance
to take the one seed in the nfc all
right rookie of the week time mds who do
you
well have have i think the obvious
choice and that's jalen hurts
like lamar jackson he had a double
triple over 100 yards
both rushing and passing and you know he
was just
so much better than carson wentz has
been
that it's hard not to question what the
eagles were thinking
waiting so long to make the switch at
quarterback i think with hertz the
eagles are
pretty clearly the best team in the nfc
east i think we're going to find that
they turn to hertz
too little too late for them to
to catch washington and the giants in
the division but
if they somehow get into the playoffs
with jalen hurts
i wouldn't want to be the wild card team
that's going to philadelphia because
that would be a tough and intriguing
game
especially early on when defensive
coordinators haven't had a lot of time
to look at jalen hurts
prepare for him i think he could really
do some damage
if the eagles get to the playoffs but i
think they're going to end up falling
short
mds i went with the obvious choice on
the defensive side of the ball and a
team that may end up winning that
in nfc east and that's chase young he's
finally starting to play like the guy
that that washington thought they were
getting with that
uh high pick and he's really playing
well but you know washington didn't
score any offensive touchdowns
they scored two on defense and he had
one of those and
second round uh safety cameron curl had
the other one but
young finished up with a sack a forced
fumble a deflected pass and that 47-yard
fumble return and i think that he's put
himself firmly in that conversation for
defensive rookie of the year just by
what he's done over the last few weeks
didn't start out as great as as he
wanted or the team wanted
but boy he's really turned it on now we
see why he was such a high pick
and week 17 we get to see jalen hurts
being chased around by chase young as
those two teams get together and there's
a chance that
if if the eagles can get some help if
they can win some games that game could
decide
the nfce championship and very likely
would be the final game of the regular
season on nbc week 17.
for me it's tuatanga viloa even though
the dolphins lost for two reasons first
of all
there really wasn't any other rookie to
give the award to this week
i checked and checked and checked and
checked and secondly
when i spoke to patrick mahomes after
the
chiefs beat the dolphins on sunday i i
asked him
about his conversations with two of
their share an agent so they have that
relationship and what
patrick mahomes said is that he was
impressed that tua
when the dolphins fell way behind didn't
try to do
too much in any one moment to make the
game
closer than it otherwise would have been
and he was patient he stayed with it my
home said when i was a young quarterback
i wouldn't have been that patient
but he was very impressed by the fact
that tua didn't freak out
and he believes that that will serve
tuatangobiloa well in the future so
he's my rookie of the week and again in
part because there was no one else to
pick
you guys squatted on the best two coach
of the week a little bit easier
more than enough to go around this week
mbs who do you have
i have colts coach frank wright who has
philip rivers playing better football
than i think people realize i don't know
if we've talked enough
about what a good season philip rivers
is having
at the age of 39 on a new team
and i think you have to give frank reich
a lot of credit for that
i think if you look at how well the
colts have played
since hiring frank wright and how much
the eagles
offense has declined since the departure
of frank wright
i really think that he has to get a lot
of credit as one of the best
offensive coaches in football both as
the eagles offensive coordinator when
they won the super bowl
as the colts head coach since then you
know
a lot could have gone wrong with this
colts team from
last year when andrew luck retired to
this year when they got philip rivers
who
some people thought was washed up and
yet frank wright just has them playing
good
solid football i really like the job
that he has done
and i think the colts are another one of
these teams who they're not the ones we
talk about
first when we talk about super bowl
contenders
but i wouldn't want to have to face them
in january i think they're going to be a
tough team to beat
mds another guy that that has done a
terrific job is sean mcdermott with
buffalo and the
the job he came in there and turned that
team around and really has them playing
at a high level a team
that as you said you wouldn't want to
play in the postseason i think they're
one of those teams that you wouldn't
want to play he's just done a masterful
job and
you know they talked the talk in the off
season they talked about tom brady being
gone and hey we're going to go out the
division's up for grabs we think it's
ours
they've backed that up this season and
really played well
uh and i think josh allen has played at
a high level and really been a
difference maker
for that team so i think sean mcdermott
deserves a lot of credit for that i
think coach of the year is going to be
really tough to figure out who that
coach of the year is but i think both of
these guys that we've mentioned frank
wright and sean mcdermott
at least deserve to be candidates for
that job for that award i think kevin
kevin stefanski i think is the winner
given what the browns have done this
year i think it's going to be hard to
take it from him
and on frank reich mds it is amazing to
think
of what could happen in the offseason
these these rumblings of carson wentz to
indy continue to grow and that could
maybe take the colts back
to the level they were at if carson
wentz really benefits from a reboot
the way that we think he could could
take them back to where they were when
they had andrew luck potentially
for me it's cliff kingsbury very simple
reason the cardinals were up against the
wall they'd lost three in a row and four
out of five
and it would have been five in a row but
for the hail murray play and
kingsbury needed a light of fire under
this team crossing the country playing a
giants team that was in first place and
on a hot streak
and to go in there and bully the giants
the way they did hassan reddick told me
after the game that they were spirited
all we can practice
that comes back to the coach you know if
if sean payton's going to say it's on me
for not
having my team ready to go then credit
the cliff kingsbury
for having his team ready to go and
prepared to win that game and turn it
around and get themselves back into the
playoff conversation mds thanks as
always
we'll be back with a week 14 re-watch
steelers it bills when pftpm continues
right after this
you